this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
when looking to buy a new macbook the
$1,300 13 inch base macbook pro is by
far the best value offering excellent
performance per dollar compared to the
rest of apple's mac books but what if
you need something a little bit more
powerful and you're not afraid to spend
some extra cash of course there's the
$1,800 13-inch MacBook Pro which bumps
you up to a more powerful quad-core
processor graphics and SSD speed as well
as getting you a couple of extra
Thunderbolt 3 ports it sounds like a
good deal for what you get but seeing as
Apple's brand-new 16 inch macbook pro is
now available you might actually be
making a huge mistake
by going with a 13-inch model so in this
video we're gonna compare the
performance specs and features of the
high-end 13-inch MacBook Pro for $1,800
to the base model 16 inch macbook pro
for $2,400 to see which one is the
better value first off the 16 inch
already comes with higher specs at the
base price like 16 gigs of ram and a 512
gigabyte SSD while the $1,800 model
comes with only 8 gigabytes of RAM and
256 gigabytes of SSD so if you match
those specs it brings the price of the
13-inch to $2,200
only $200 off the price of the 16 inch
and that's what the quad core i5
processor on the 13 inch instead of a 6
core i7 on the 16 inch pro in our
13-inch model actually has 16 gigabytes
of RAM since most people looking at the
high-end definitely don't want to be
limited by only 8 gigabytes of RAM
now before we compare the performance of
both machines let's compare some of the
feature differences between both of them
the display quality on each model is
basically the same with the same color
accuracy brightness and pixels per inch
but the 16 inch actually has thinner
bezels which look quite a bit nicer and
more modern the 16 inch also has the
updated scissor mechanism keyboard which
honestly is world's better than the
butterfly keyboard on the 13-inch pro
it's got a lot more key travel and
features a physical Escape key so the
keyboard by itself may push a lot of
people to choose the 16 inch instead and
for those who like large track pads the
one on the 16 inch is larger as well and
when it come
speaker quality the 16-inch destroys the
speakers on the 13-inch just hear it for
yourself
[Music]
and finally the microphone quality is
quite a bit better on the 16 inch pro as
well this is a microphone quality test
with the $1,800 13 inch MacBook Pro this
is a microphone sound quality test with
the new 16 inch MacBook Pro the only
downside of the larger model is
portability it's quite a bit larger than
13-inch MacBook and 4.3 pounds instead
of 3 pounds on the smaller pro so it's
not going to be as easy to carry around
but the benefit is of course the larger
display since the 13-inch pros display
is simply too small for a lot of people
out there including myself so even
before considering performance
differences the 16 inch already seems
like a better deal for all of those
extra feature improvements that you get
now before we get into comparing
performance let me tell you about our
sponsor Squarespace if you've been
thinking about making your own website
Squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
I built an engaging website for my
wife's cleaning business with literally
no web making experience you just choose
a template customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and it's
been running flawlessly for almost two
years bringing in new clients thanks to
its built-in SEO tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
for literally anything else go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and use
our custom link below when you're ready
to launch - save 10% on your first
purchase of a website or domain starting
performance testing with Geekbench 5s
raw CPU power test the base 16 inch pro
is 34 percent faster which is a decent
jump in performance for the extra cash
in the more realistic cinnamon chart 20
stress tests the 16 inch pro was 51
percent faster so that means the better
cooling system and cores allow the
processors to run even faster than the
13-inch model we then tested graphics
performance and geek benches mettle test
and here we saw a massive difference
with the 16 inch pro being about three
times faster which is due to the fact
that you actually get a dedicated
graphics chip in its AMD's latest and
greatest navi 7 nanometer graphics as
well to test gaming for
we're an Unigine seven benchmark on the
extreme preset and the 16 inch probe got
over four times the FPS that's a massive
improvement for the relatively small
price job and we actually tested gaming
performance and call of duty modern
warfare so if you want to see that video
click the button at the end of this one
we then tested GFX bench 5.0 and the
16-inch got over tripled the FPS in the
Aztek test in over five times the FPS in
the main Hatun test so there definitely
is a huge difference in graphics
performance now before we get into the
real world video editing test we also
tested the speeds of the SSD storage and
since the sixteen inch comes with a 512
gigabyte SSD instead of only 256 gigs
with a 13-inch we got over double the
writing speed and for read speeds the
sixteen inch got over 300 megabytes per
second more than the 13-inch so that's
another nice bonus you get by going with
a 16 inch model let's start out Final
Cut Pro 10 video editing tests with a
graphically demanding Bruce X test and
here the 16 inch Pro finished over three
times faster than the 13-inch Pro
stabilizing a 20 second 4k clip took
only seven and a half seconds on the
larger model compared to 33 seconds on
the 13 that extra time can easily add up
if your stabilizing multiple Clips we
ran that same test except with a 30
second c200 rock clip and the 13 inch
took over five times as long to
stabilize a clip now moving on to
exporting a five-minute 4k h.264 clip
with added effects which is the format
that most youtubers shoot and edit the
13-inch proud took over three times as
long to finish the export and ask for
the actual editing part the clip and the
timeline didn't playback at the full 30
frames per second so it wasn't a
perfectly smooth editing experience
either now moving on to some heavier
duty file formats like exporting a
five-minute 4.5 K read raw clip the
13-inch pro took 37 minutes to export
almost four times slower than the 16
inch pro and then in an even more
extreme test the 60 p c200 raw
five-minute export the 13-inch pro took
over five times as long a full hour in
14 minutes compared to just 14 minutes
with the suit
snitch pro and you can easily see the
difference during playback the 16 inch
plays it at almost the full 60 frames
per second so it's actually bearable to
edit compared to the stuttery 13-inch
pro's performance not only that but you
can easily see how much more screen
space you get for editing on the larger
model so the 16 inch pro is the obvious
choice for video editors from all these
tests and benchmarks we can see that the
new 16 inch MacBook Pro blows the 13
inch pro away in terms of performance so
after seeing all of that there are only
two downsides to the 16 inch pro the
higher base price of 2400 dollars in the
larger size which leads to worse
portability to be honest the performance
is so much better that I would
personally suck it up and live with
carrying around the larger model
especially considering the much better
speakers and larger display and asked
for the price if there's no way that you
can stretch your budget enough to get
the 16 inch Pro I would honestly just
buy the base $1300 13 inch MacBook Pro
because it's not that much lower than
the $1,800 13 inch model as you guys saw
in our which MacBook to buy video that
I'll link to at the end of this video
and finally there's just one more option
if you want more performance but don't
want to spend the extra cash on a 16
inch Pro Apple is rumored to be
releasing a new updated 14 inch macbook
pro sometime in 2020 so if you can wait
that long that's a great choice as well
if you enjoyed this comparison make sure
to tap that like button and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out those
two videos that I mentioned over there
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]